[Music]
2016
the hubble space telescope turned toward
a dark patch of sky
in the constellation ursa major
[Applause]
[Music]
it captured an image of an indistinct
blob of light the glow
is from a distant galaxy called gn
z11
the most distant galaxy we've ever
observed
but is this the edge of the universe
the universe all around us is filled
with galaxies
so it's kind of natural to say would
there be a final galaxy if you traveled
far enough away would you finally be at
the very last galaxy in the universe
looking out into empty space
that's a difficult question to answer
because there's a limit to how far we
can see
it all comes down to the speed of light
and the age of the universe
the key to understanding the edge of the
universe
is that light travels very very fast
but not infinitely fast it takes time
for it to get from one place in the
universe to the other
you open the curtains light fills the
room it doesn't seem to travel at all
but over the vast distances of the
universe you actually notice this travel
time
[Music]
even the sun 93 million miles away the
light takes eight minutes to get to us
when you look out at the stars we start
to think of distance in terms of light
years
because it takes years for the light to
get from those stars to us
and then when you look at galaxies then
you're talking about millions or
billions of light years
when we look at the light from galaxy
gnz11
we're seeing light emitted 13.4 billion
years ago
you can't really even find a galaxy too
much farther away than that
because the universe is only 13.8
billion years old
and it takes a certain amount of time
for galaxies to even form
so we're not going to find too many more
galaxies farther away than this
if things are far enough away there is
no way that light can get to us
in the age of the universe what this
means is there's a hard limit
to the edge of the universe that we can
see and this is set
by the age of the universe
gn sparked into life early
in the history of the universe just 400
million years
after the big bang before that
there were no stars to send out light
if you look in any direction at all you
get all the way back to when there were
no stars
no galaxies nothing but very very hot
gas
and that sort of forms a shell around us
that outer shell is the cosmic microwave
background it is the oldest
light in the universe the echo
of the birth of the universe the big
bang
the edge of our universe the very
furthest thing that we can see
is one of the earliest relics of the
formation of the universe itself
that is the cosmic microwave background
we call this the edge of our
observable universe so we have an
observable universe
but beyond that even if there are things
out there there's no way we can see them
because the light just could not have
gotten to us by now
as the name states the observable
universe is simply the part of the
universe
we can see we can think of the
observable universe as sort of like a
spotlight
centered on wherever you're standing
right now and you can see to the edge of
your spotlight
and not beyond
[Music]
but if you move a little bit to the left
a little bit to the right
your observable universe actually moves
with you
for someone living in galaxy gnz11 a
totally different part of the universe
would be observable
so that distant galaxy is at the edge of
our observable universe
and we are at the edge of their
observable universe
we have different spotlights one of the
wonderful things to think about is that
there are other spheres around other
galaxies there are other aliens looking
up into the sky tonight
wondering what the true extent of the
universe is
the true extent of our universe doesn't
end
with galaxy gnz11
[Music]
but when astronomers use the hubble
space telescope
to accurately measure the distance to
gnz 11
they find something shocking
it's 32 billion light years away
three times further than thought
possible
so if nothing can travel faster than
light and we measure the distance
to this galaxy how can it be 32 billion
light years away
there hasn't been enough time in the
history of the universe
for light from gn z11 to reach us
there must be some mistake here right
at this point your brain is probably
thinking of leaping out of your skull
and running around screaming
trust me i know i'm an astronomer i've
been doing this my whole life and this
stuff
twists my imagination up it's really
hard to grasp this
how do we see a galaxy that's 32 billion
light years away
and only 13.4 billion years old
gnz 11 is further away than it should be
because something strange is going on
with our universe
it's expanding and if the universe
is expanding then where does its edge
lie
and can we ever reach it